so what exactly is the Democratic Border
Security proposal would it actually
secure the border well we had some time
today so we checked and in a word no it
would not the Democratic bill in the
Senate that it was just telling you
about simply restores previous funding
levels for the Border Patrol and other
existing programs so you have to ask
yourself when you consider that was the
border secure in December before the
shutdown well no it wasn't and that's
why we're having this debate right now
then how would it be more secure after a
bill that doesn't change anything
passes well it wouldn't be more secure
and that's the point of the legislation
to maintain the broken status quo let's
be honest about that meanwhile in the
House Homeland Security Committee
Chairman Bennie Thompson says he plans
to introduce a bill that contains
billions for border security but nothing
for a wall Thompson is a brand-new idea
he's telling us he says he can secure
the border with the marvels of
technology he recently told PBS that
cutting edge machines can help us quote
identify those vulnerabilities on the
border Thompson's plan can expect
enthusiastic support from the
congressman from tech line Speaker of
the House Nancy Pelosi hears her most
recent suggestion for the border watch
the positive shall we say almost
technological wall that can be built is
what we should be doing technology to
scan the cars coming through the ports
of entry and that is to detect guns it's
like an electronic dog almost difficult
to detect drugs guns and other
contraband it's really like an
electronic dog that can detect
contraband one level that's hilarious
we've laughed about it before but it's
also patronizing really you'd have to be
totally ignorant of what's happening on
our southern border to believe that more
surveillance is going to solve the
problem we have an awful lot of
surveillance technology there already
we've got drones cameras sensors radar
dirigibles we have it there in part
because the Bush administration put it
there that administration spent more
than a billion dollars on something
called the secure border initiative
network they use technology to watch off
50 miles of our southern border
congressman Bennie Thompson himself
called that probe
quote grave and expensive disappointment
well Tasha was right about that
which change is that Democrats now
support grave inexpensive
disappointments they specialize in grave
and expensive disappointments they're
pushing one now and that's short-sighted
leaving a politics aside is not a good
idea because our southern border is one
of America's most dangerous
vulnerabilities that's not a talking
point it's literally true and here's why
as of tonight Mexico is an intact
country will it remain an intact country
maybe but maybe not
Mexico is a deeply unstable place it's
not an attack on the Mexican people it's
an acknowledgement of what anyone who
knows anything about the country will
tell you the National murder rate in
Mexico is five times ours since 2006
more than 250,000 a quarter million
people have been murdered in Mexico that
includes hundreds of politicians and
judges there's a war going on there and
it's spurred by drug cartels that reach
into the highest levels of the Mexican
government not an exaggeration the
Attorney General of an entire Mexican
state recently pleaded guilty to drug
trafficking charges the governor of a
state on the US border took bribes to
let cartels operate freely which they
did and then just the other day mexico's
previous president was credibly accused
at trial in court by a witness of taking
a hundred million dollar bribe from el
chapo guzman in effect Mexico has become
a narco-state but it's not even those
volatile country in the region Nicaragua
is in severe turmoil right now that gets
no coverage but it's real parts of El
Salvador are largely controlled by gangs
Venezuela meanwhile is literally falling
apart
a recent Brookings Institution report
predicted that a total collapse of
Venezuela which could happen any day
might create 8 million refugees for
perspective that's more refugees than
fled the entire Syrian civil war and
keep in mind that that flood of humanity
upended all of Europe something similar
could easily happen here to us and it
likely will if we ignore the problem
which we are doing and yet the position
of Democrats in the Congress is that
everything is fine and you're nuts if
you disagree nothing needs to be done
well that's the definition of
recklessness in fact
worse than recklessness it's like
letting your kids play in traffic you
wouldn't do that to people you care to
bet you'd prevent it from happening
Democrats have become extremists on the
question of borders but you never know
that from watching television reading
the paper the media won't say it and
normal most Republicans by the way even
in the Trump administration some
officials seem intent on making Nancy
Pelosi's case for her the Republicans
the real extremists here here's what
commerce secretary Wilbur Ross said
today when he was asked about workers
who aren't being paid during the
shutdown the people might have to pay a
little bit of interest but the idea that
it's paycheck or zero is not a really
valid idea
there have been ads run by a number of
the public sector credit unions those
have been ounce very very low interest
rate flows to bridge people over the gap
so more debt more interest payments
that's the solution no it's not those
are the last things that most Americans
need that was an idiotic thing to say
look for Wilbur Ross's words to be aired
every day for the next three years on
CNN they know a propaganda win when they
see one and it's a shame and it's also a
distraction because it doesn't change
the nature the fundamental nature of
this crisis our borders remain
vulnerable and the stakes are higher
than they have ever been thanks to the
chaos just south of them leaders who
cared about this country would be
staying up late trying to fix that
problem Democratic leaders are trying to
make it worse that's the bottom line
truth